Animators use a variety
of tools for accurately
enveloping characters.
However, the models
produced by these tools
are often too slow for use in
high-performance applications,
such as training
simulations and video games.
We propose a technique
that can learn
from a set of
exported example poses
and generate a fast
and accurate model
for high-speed evaluation.
Our model is also
much more expressive
than linear blend
skinning, currently
the most common enveloping model
for real-time applications.
We tested our technique
on a variety of examples,
including muscle bulging,
shoulder deformation,
skin sliding, and twisting.
We can accurately express
joints with more than 1 degree
of freedom, like the shoulder.
Here, we illustrate rotations
along all 3 degrees of freedom.
Whereas shoulder is often
cause problems for SSD,
our result is almost
indistinguishable
from the ground truth.
Our model can accurately
approximate the deformations
from human scan data.
Here, we demonstrate
our technique,
blending between
human scan poses.
Our model can express large
muscle bulges as well,
such as at the knee of this leg,
and roughly approximate skin
sliding over bone.
Here, we have no problems
modeling the large arms
and shoulders of
the gorilla figure,
while SSD causes
collapsing artifacts.
Our model even works
well with this set
of artist-generated
extreme poses.
There has been a rich
body of prior work
that has tried to address
the deficiencies of SSD.
Displacement
interpolating techniques,
such as post-based defamation,
add corrective displacements
to an existing SSD model, but
generalize poorly for cases
in which SSD cannot approximate
the rotational deformations.
Our model correctly captures
the twisting present
in both the bar and the elbow.
Twisting motion is especially
troublesome for SSD,
requiring the displacement
interpolation techniques
to capture extreme
corrective displacements.
Because our model captures
rotations much better,
we complement existing
displacement interpolation
techniques by providing
an alternative to SSD.
Previous work has also
inserted halfway joints
to try to prevent blending
of large rotations.
Because this approach inserts
these joints a priori,
it does not always
generalize well.
For instance, consider an
anatomically inspired arm rake
in which the elbow
both bends and twists.
We compare our
technique with that
of Mohr and Gleicher and SSD.
The twisting motion is enough
to impair the SSD prediction.
Mohr and Gleicher's
technique does better,
but there are still differences.
Our result is almost
indistinguishable
from the ground truth.
Finally, our model generalizes
well to unseen poses.
In this example,
we show our model
evaluated on a completely
novel test sequence.